do you believe a screenwriter should
write their first draft as quickly as
possible ah speed yes and here's why so
I might my hel job I've had several held
jobs but one of the hell jobs was USA
Network had a script fall out and so a
producer for them called me up and said
bill we know that you can write somewhat
fast we need a script and so we have
this location that we've already rented
and we need you to tour the location and
come back to us tomorrow and print it
and pitch us maybe four or five script
ideas so I toured the location and came
back and pitched four or five script
ideas which by the way if you write down
script ideas when you come up with them
and put them like in a notebook later on
you can come up with four or five script
ideas right off the top of your head
because you just flip them up a good hey
that can work in that location but
anyway I went back and pitched him and
after pitching it they you know we liked
that one and we need to have a first
draft in 14 days and I said are you
kidding
so nope 14 days because the shooting
schedule for USA Network they literally
had a hole that was like whatever
whatever their movie was 8 p.m. on
Friday night or whatever would be a test
pattern unless I wrote the script and
they made the film so it was a situation
where in the real world there is their
real deadlines and my deadline now was
14 days to write a script and they said
by the way that's the script we're
taking out to talent so it can't be bad
we're gonna try to get actors off this
script and because it's USA Network we
don't really pay a lot so you know we're
gonna we're gonna try to find actors who
are will work for less than their rate
and I went fine so what I learned is
that when you have an insane deadline
like that you write fast you cut through
to your subconscious completely you
basically it's a direct line instead of
your brain going well I don't know if
that that seems too personal
all of those blocks that you usually put
between you and writing can't be there
you now have to produce pages and so you
end up writing a more personal script a
more a script that gets right into the
icky stuff inside of us we don't want to
deal with because you don't have time to
put up
walls there's just no time for the walls
so you write fast you come up with I
think a better script one of the things
I learned on that was I wrote my script
in 12 days and spent two days on a
rewrite before I handed it in and what I
learned is the two days made that script
a million times better because I came up
with all kinds of great things that had
been suggested as I was writing it but
hadn't fully formed until you know fade
out and that's like now I can go back
and put this in and this and this in and
it'll be a much better script so if
you're ever writing on a deadline always
take extra time to do that final shoot
through
you